i'm getting stronger every day
i'm glad to hear her
i'm very excited that steffy and fan are
back together
you know they've
there's this energy about them and
steffy really feels safe with finn and
she doesn't really feel safe with a lot
of people so i'm so happy that this was
able to work out and they finally
reunite
wow
it's not quite as romantic as monica
oh it definitely is
it was hot it was a hot it was yes
they haven't seen each other in months
she thought he was dead
she was gonna climb him like a tree the
problem is with us because when we do
work together a canadian accent comes
out so in between the scenes it's
yeah do you wanna do it without the
hockey game yeah oh yeah oh yeah i was
up there too uh gosh this was had it's
tim hortons there right you know oh and
they're like uh jackie tanner
canadians coming out
ever since the shooting
finn coming back into my life like i
realized life is too precious you gotta
go out there
get what you want i
love stephie fans they are
riot they are you know they make me
smile because their messages their dms
like i think
steffie is a sassy character no
no the steffi fans that's where i'm
pulling from their one-liners are so
good
they just
they put a smile on my face every single
day
[Music]
i had my baby brando i had him
may 19th my oldest was incredible he
is three and he was so good my he was
and then lennox
was 15 months so i brought him home and
he didn't quite understand like he knew
it was baby but it was you know him
rolling on him and it was a really good
arm workout for me because i was just
like lifting them 24 7 up and down up
and down the stairs and that was how i
was getting my work at it work out in
really
but uh yeah it's been really it's been
really really good